Johns do not fit into neat stereotypes.
But there is one universal truth:
no John, no buyer, no victim.
So if we want to start to put a dent in sex trafficking,
we have to get to John.
And businesses can do that while he's at work.
There's an organization called Businesses Ending Slavery and Trafficking,
or BEST for short.
And when they launched in 2012,
they did a study of Seattle-based Johns.
And you know what they found out?
Johns are everyday guys, employed at local businesses.
They range in age from 18 to 84.
Johns are dads.
Johns have admitted that they buy sex when they are traveling for business,
when they're going to sporting events
or when they're in the military.
But here's the kicker.
BEST study determined that web-based sex buying
spikes at 2pm in the afternoon.
Which means that these Johns are likely buying sex in the middle of the workday.
I believe that there is a way to stop Johns in the middle of the workday
from buying sex.
And businesses can do it in three simple ways.
The first is with a policy.
A policy that clearly says,
the company prohibits sex-buying during work,
with company resources or on company time.
That's right.
I'm saying that your handbook has to specifically give an example
that says no sex-buying while you're traveling,
at the international trade show, because that's where it's happening.
Now, a policy is only as good as its enforcement and its communication.
Several studies have indicated from Johns
that the best way to deter them is public humiliation and embarrassment.
So, businesses who catch Johns buying sex,
using company-based equipment or company resources,
but cut them a break or sweep it under the rug
and don't fire them,
are complicit in fueling demand.
Now, a policy is one of the best ways to start.
The second way is educating the workforce.
Businesses can go a long way in simply training their workforce
about the signs and the red flags of human trafficking.
This was my "aha!" moment for how our company could make a big difference.
Our nation's highways, airports and truck stops
are literally used as modern-day slave routes.
Our company has more than 100,000 drivers
all over the country, all over the world.
And so it made perfect sense to train them to see the red flags.
We don't want them jumping out there and doing things on their own,
so we want them to call a phone number, the hotline,
and let law enforcement intervene.
So to do this, we teamed up
with an organization called Truckers Against Trafficking.
This Colorado-based organization had web-based support and materials
that we gave to our truck drivers
that gave them exactly what they needed to spot the red flags.
Like, hearing CB chatter on their radios about girls at nearby exits.
Or, seeing underaged women emerging from vehicles
in the truck stop parking lots.
When we rolled out this training,
a few brave drivers admitted they had seen these women,
knocking on the cabs in the truck stops, looking for customers.
Now, they said that they weren't buying.
But they also didn't know enough to make a call.
And that's what we want them to do.
TAT's organization -- Truckers Against Trafficking --
also emphasizes the need for men to talk to other men
about web-based sex buying and not buying commercial sex.
They feature men in uniform, proudly proclaiming why they don't buy.
If we're going to see a cultural shift in this atrocity,
we need men talking to other men
about the underlying issues fueling demand.
Because sometimes, Johns don't even know
that they're purchasing girls who are enslaved.
Which brings me to my final way that businesses can help.
Every business has a special resource
or a secret sauce or resource that they can bring
to fight human trafficking.
For example, Visa, Master Card and American Express
refuse to process transactions from backpage.com,
an online sex site that sold commercial sex
to the tune of nine million dollars a month.
In April of 2018, backpage.com and affiliated websites were shut down,
and the FBI seized all their assets.
Hiring survivors is another way that any company can help.
Randstad, an organization that works with companies
to find survivors who need good jobs,
has an excellent program, called Hire Hope.
We've used this program; we know that it works.
In addition to training their flight attendants
and their airline crew,
Delta Air Lines also offers SkyMiles, through a program called SkyWish,
to survivors to help them escape their traffickers
and reunite with their families.
There are thousands of things that businesses can do.
They just have to decide what to do to join the fight.
No one can justify slavery today.
But I believe it remains one of the greatest civil rights atrocities
of our time.
Fortunately, the business community is uniquely positioned
to help train their employees,
to enforce policies
and to help use their special resources
to fight human trafficking.
And what about you?
What if you decided to learn the red flags?
What if you decided to look at the signs that are all around you
and make a call?
There is no penalty for calling law enforcement
when you see something that doesn't sit right.
Together, we can all protect our children,
we can educate the workforces around us
and improve society,
where we all live and work with John.
Thank you.
(Applause)